>> Well, the question in my mind is what's
the most exciting
innovation, development of the next decade
that will improve the state
of the world?
As far as I'm concerned, that is the full
integration of women into
political participation, into economic participation,
into ensuring
that all girls around the world receive the
same education as boys.
And that the wealth of resources of countries
divided equally between
men and women, because we're beginning to
see now some of the results
of having women more actively in the public
sphere.
And those results look pretty darn good.
And so to me, we need to continue that innovation
for getting women
more into the public sphere and I would hope
and think that it will --
what I call -- her history.